we were wrapping it up with the mixing
and all that the conversation tick-tock
came up a lot right so i'm like tikka
tokahu tiktok might be the new hot spot
for musicians but adele isn't feeling it
and staying true to herself
the 33 year old grammy winner sits down
with zane lowe for apple music to talk
all things 30. her highly anticipated
fourth studio album that's set to drop
on november 19th i feel amazing about it
and during the chat adele says while she
was recording her new music there was a
lot of talk about catering to the tick
tock audience they're like you know
we've got to make sure these 14 year
olds know who you are i'm like but
they've all got mums they've all got
mums and i've they've definitely been
growing up listening to my music these
foot really rolls and stuff like that
but it was like if everyone's making
music for the tick tock who's making the
music for my generation who's making the
music for my peers i will do that job
gladly i'd rather cater to people that
have like
are on my level in terms of like the
amount of time we've spent on earth and
all the things we've been through adele
even goes so far as to say her music
isn't for the young tic tac generation
but rather for people who are in the
same season of life that she's in i
don't want 12 years listening to this
record it's a bit too deep but the 30
and four-year-olds are all committing to
themselves and doing therapy
that's my vibe yeah because that's what
i was doing yeah you know so i'm more
concerned with how this record can help
them and to further prove that her music
isn't necessarily for kids she admits
that her nine-year-old son angelo isn't
exactly streaming her tunes
i mean
anjo's not a fan of mine
but he's just like yeah he thinks
yeah when her kiddo hears the words
rolling in the deep the title of adele's
hit track from 2012
[Music]
he doesn't think of his famous mom he
thinks of astronaut in the ocean by
masked wolf
what you know about rolling down in the
deep when your brain goes numb you
you know whatever he doesn't really care
it's great
of course the hello singer revealed
during her cbs primetime special adele
one night only that her son had never
heard her perform live until then this
is the first time that my son has ever
seen me perform
and i got really uh and dressed up for
me it was a i'm gonna cry anyways but um
it's the absolute honor of my life baby
to have you here tonight
and you look so beautiful and so
handsome and smart and during her sit
down with oprah winfrey she said her
little one was just starting to
understand what his mom does for a
living does angelo know that you are
adele
no apart from the other day he watched
the easy on me video like countdown to
when it premiered he was like there was
like a hundred and fifty thousand people
waiting and that blah blah and he had
all these likes and then he read the
comments and then
he was like people really like you